except that that is good enough that is  and if you go Rook D4 at the very least  yeah at the very least we have this no  funky stalemates luckily yeah the king  in the center  okay he's played Queen H4 we shouldn't  have doubted him and yeah five finger  five yeah okay king of five has maybe  also being being bored with the game a  little bit I'm not bored but like  understanding where it's headed  yeah well played abdicator of impressive  okay absolutely yeah  uh Parham fought well as well so  credit to both of them absolutely and in  the other one this is now the position  of how did we get there  looks like yeah still okay still okay  for black obviously and uh  not that easy to completely spoil as  long as you don't blunder like the  pollination